mark asks who are the idols of the  people that inspire you did you ever  have a mentor mark you know for people  that watched me or have followed me over  the last seven or eight years this is a  very easy answer I've been very hardcore  about this I have never really been a  big fan of any business idols including  the before-mentioned more Cuban or you  know really the two entrepreneurs or  people that have ever kind of over  indexed to me where Walt is the and  Vince McMahon because they were heavy  storytellers and turned businesses out  of that I like that but to say they were  my mentors or I looked up to them there  is no Steve Jobs or Donald Trump's or  Carnegie's or there is nothing like that  in my life my life is really focused on  two individuals Tamara and Sasha  Vaynerchuk tomorrow from the HR people  skill foundation Sasha from the work  ethic you know we mentioned that in  Episode three or four so you know  they're really my only mentors that's it